feels unreal it's like the ideal thing
as a filmmaker that your four lead
actors would all get Oscar Noms and then
they all get to go party together like
everybody gets to come it's like what a
miracle we all get to kind of like
support each other through this like
Adventure that literally none of us have
ever done you know
that's Daniel Quan and Daniel scheiner
known as Daniels they prefer Daniels
without the D the pair met as film
students at Emerson College in Boston
and now they share the Oscars for best
director and best original screenplay
along with the big one best picture
imagine sharing that with your best
friend